he is the governor of Washington State
and a 2020 Democratic presidential
candidate governor jay Inslee seems like
you were just tear your back last time
you hurt you were not a presidential
candidate now you are so is there any
increased stature just oh no for money
no but you know we have the Green Party
know in years past I didn't get much it
seems like you're now a one-man Green
Party if having made that you're you
know you're sort of a one-issue
candidate which i think is the issue
I've always said that yeah most
important issue is that a fair way to
characterize it you are the Green Party
within the Democratic Party know I would
rephrase it that I am the Democratic one
man person who intends to make Donald
Trump a blip in history that's what I
would say look I'm a Democrat and I got
into this race because I know we have
one last chance to defeat climate change
and it is a last chance we've got to
count down the road for 30 years and I
got it in this race because I got three
grandkids and I'm gonna look them in the
eye and make sure I've told it was done
everything I could it's amazing in the
last presidential election in the
debates it wasn't even an issue at Cal
minutes it's for men even among the
Democrats yeah yeah so this time it's
gonna be different well this is why I'm
getting the party to have a debate
exclusively around Clyde no I think
we're all on the page that it hasn't at
least be admitted a here's the problem
climate change initiatives were on the
ballot in 2018 yeah almost every state
said no and when you ask even people
people have come around now to agreeing
yes it is a problem right man-made we
should do something when the next
question is would you be willing to
spend $10 a month mm-hmm
68% of people say no so they don't put
the money where their mouth is well
that's why do we get around that well we
make sure that the people pay in the $10
a month are the oil companies were
taking 27 billion dollars in attack
subsidies we got to retrieve that 27
billion dollars and to put it in clean
energy and today I rolled out a big bold
and ambitious program because we're a
big bold ambitious country that in fact
will put the onus on them you know they
always talk about the Republicans well
how you gonna pay for it how are they
gonna pay for paradise California that
burned down okay but I mean at some
point I mean people talk about a carbon
tax which i think is a terrible name is
usually Democrats bad at naming things
that call it a pro-life initiative you
know throw life on earth you know
something okay but at some point we are
going to have to make it a cost to be a
polluter or just a pig or just sloppy
and we don't do we are afraid as always
in America to confront the people yeah
well we're not confronting the people
we're standing with them and I'll tell
you what we did today I rolled out a
this plan to defeat climate change with
mayor Garcetti with me that will do
three things number one it will
guarantee Americans that we have a
hundred percent clean electricity no
coal after 2030 we need to wean
ourselves off of coal okay but let me
stop you there I hear this all the time
electricity is not brought by a ferry
yes it
I don't know what you mean what I mean
is people think it's free it's the Sun
that doesn't cause any pollution wind
doesn't write not electricity
electricity comes from natural gas oil
coal so I have an electric car mm-hmm
but when I plug it in that electricity
came from somewhere other than just free
well today I was at the bus barn with
mayor Garcetti where they are charging
electric buses with solar panels right
in the charging solar panels and we have
to understand what has happened the coal
plants have gone from a thousand plants
to about three hundred because they just
aren't competitive and we have to
understand that we are the most
innovative country in world history and
today clean energy jobs not for a long
time twice as fast cleaner jobs going
yeah it's as fast as the rest of the
economy and look at wind turbines don't
cause cancer Trump is wrong they cause
jobs okay cause jobs and that's what we
believe
I mean look we are still the great
innovators in tech and I think people
think we can invent our way out of this
but I don't think we can I don't think
you can invent your way out of well I'm
gonna beg to differ a little bit look
look at what's happened in solar energy
I wrote a co-authored a book in 2007
about this and I said Solar is gonna
come on like gangbusters since that time
the cost of solar energy has come down
80% and it is continuing to drop well
most of wind power has come down 20% but
what percentage of the grid is Sun and
solar small now so six eight nine
percent but so it didn't come on like
out it's good well no it is it's growing
it three two hundred three and a percent
and what we can get let me give an
example what I mean by this just one
factual example they say we can't
achieve my goal which is to have
electric cars by 2030 look a little
electric car that's correct the new cars
he's buying in 2030 that's that's in my
proposal in 1940 the united states total
made 77 jeeps four years later we had
made six hundred and forty thousand
jeeps if we mobilize this nation right
we can build a clean energy economy we
just need a can-do president also and
when world war two got started
we stopped making cars well no cars
really well this turned it all into tank
factory Stein factory the only cars were
like big cars for generals to ride
around with the flag at the generation
this time we're gonna have car okay well
we're gonna have electric cars like I
have look I argue to Megan McCain she
said you know I read cards I said look
at a GM bolt all-electric bolt made by
American Auto Workers in Orion Michigan
that's a destiny for America the jobs in
this country okay but important question
mm-hmm they're all you're arguing with
Meghan McCain
[Laughter]
what about nuclear now that's one that
divides liberals I'm a sudden I mean
yeah ask me one day I'm for it Monday
I'm against it yeah I don't know I mean
obviously it's clean it's also like if
there's a problem right it's altered
ultra dirty yeah and really bad so you
know where you on that my view is that
we have to be serious about any
potential zero low carb or a system yes
well if this is an if if you can make it
cost-effective if you can make it safer
and if you can resolve the nuclear waste
problem if you can do those things it
could be part of the possibility no no
but you got to do that because we
haven't done those things for Decco
here's what I believe I believe we
should do research and development yeah
and out whether or not whether or not we
can surmount those problems and if we
can it could be part of the solution so
I support that Rd because this is an
urgent problem that's my view okay so
I'm with you both ways all right thank
you very much for doing this you've got
a great issue
[Applause]
you